Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Aboard Oasis of the Seas.
I partnered with Royal Caribbean International
to travel the Atlantic Ocean in order to see
the great American solar eclipse in totality.
Which is what, exactly?
This is the Sun, Moon and Earth.
A solar eclipse occurs when the moon passes
between the Sun and Earth.
Casting a shadow on the Earth.
If you're in that shadow, called the Umbra,
you're in what's called the path of totality.
And you will see the total solar eclipse.
The last solar eclipse to touch exclusively
on lands now part of the United States was
in 1257.
Which was a long time ago.
But I’m not seeing this one on land.
I’m 400 miles off the east coast on one
of the largest cruise ships in the world.
I’m seeing the total eclipse at sea.
See?
The Sun is 400 times larger than the Moon
but it's also 400 times further away.
This celestial coincidence is what allows
the moon to perfectly cover up the Sun.
1% of the sun is 10,000 times brighter than
the full moon which is why the darkness of
the total eclipse is so unique.
First contact is about to start so lets head
to the top deck.
We’re entering totality.
Two minutes and thirty eight seconds.
That's how long I spent in totality.
Shrouded in the Moon's shadow, witnessing
a brief alteration of reality.
The total solar eclipse is the clearest reminder
that while the celestial bodies are always
moving, every now and then, things line up
just right and it reignites our curiosity
in the cosmos.
And all they ask in return is that we sit
back and enjoy the view.
And as always - thanks for watching.
Hey!
Gigantic thanks to Royal Caribbean International
for inviting me to be a part of this once-in-a-lifetime
moment.
Here on Oasis of the Seas.
Royal Caribbean has a long history of ground-breaking
innovations and first-at-sea experiences from
surf simulators and a zip line to world-class
dining.
I mean, this ship is so huge it literally
has seven neighborhoods.
I had an awesome time, the entire staff was
super nice and helpful and I just want to
thank them for supporting science, supporting
learning and supporting Vsauce.